hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're going to be chatting about
my office because I've been getting a
lot of questions since I've just posted
a video to hopefully answer a lot of
your questions about what gear do I use
but then that video and up spawning more
questions about what's your office like
where do you work what do you edit with
so I thought I would make this video to
give you guys a quick little update on
what I've got going on because I
mentioned in a previous vlog I had an
organizer come in professional organizer
like this is a thing like these people
are absolutely incredible one of my
downfalls is organization and I have
very very poor organizational skills
like every bachelor if it's just me but
I feel like a lot of creative people we
spend so much time creating that the
rest of our lives sometimes get out of
control now not only is their
organization involved but there are some
closet build-outs happening as well I
have one master closet being built out
so this is what this is gonna look like
but this is what it looks like now and
if you guys can see all of these bins
all of these things will eventually have
a home now all of these things in these
bins came from places all around my
house from my drawers from downstairs
from upstairs from my bedroom everything
that essentially didn't belong in the
place that it was has now ended up in
these bins and they'll soon will end up
in this closet that's not a closet yet
this little space right here will
hopefully look like this I'm so excited
because the first few phases of this
entire process is over and when I say it
was insane like everything that I had in
my house everywhere was out in the open
like it was just so nuts but anyway this
is my current office setup so I kind of
wanted to do a before and then an after
and also we'll get some suggestions from
you guys because I'm having a very big
dilemma but more on that later
obviously the centerpiece of my office
is right here this is my LG OLED
wallpaper TV I did an unboxing and setup
video of this previously so I'll put a
link in the description and up here in
the little I if you guys want to check
that out but this thing is awesome it's
one of those things when you're sitting
and watching it that it feels so
realistic that it sort of almost
confuses my mind like I forget that I am
looking at a television the fact that
it's so thin it actually blew the minds
of the guys that were installing it they
were like this is crazy we've never even
installed one of these before and they
did an absolutely incredible job so my
face to sort of for this TV setup is I
really want to get this cable behind the
wall and that's something that I'm gonna
have to enlist a professional to do
because clearly I don't think I'm
capable
now this cable is very important because
this attaches to of the sound bar here
now the sound bar is not just for sound
this powers the entire screen so you
plug everything right here into the back
of the sound bar this is where the HDMI
goes and right now we have the new 4k
Apple TV hooked up which I haven't even
got a chance to try yet so you guys will
be witnessing my first time trying it
out one of my favorite things other than
these beyond incredible picture quality
of this television is that the sound bar
has Dolby Atmos so when I'm sitting and
watching TV and I turn up that volume it
feels like you're in a movie theater it
feels like I actually have surround
sound set up in this room which I don't
using the Dolby Atmos it's able to give
you that feel I wish that I could show
you in this video what it's like but I
can't
except for flailing my arms around you
something kidding is so excited
one of the things that I was excited
about with this TV when I first got it
was the future of the things that I
could use with it
the first thing has arrived is the Apple
4k TV now I'll be able to take full
advantage of the perfect color quality
on this TV it's kind of crazy because
the LG OLED pixels can switch off
completely what this means is black is
actually black pitch black
so this is still a part of the TV right
here this is still a part of TV and the
regs are redder like the colors are so
incredibly vivid like I said before it's
kind of a surreal experience
bye-bye
oh my god one of the movies that I was
excited about that was in 4k HDR
spider-man haven't seen it I've heard
great things so that's something the
first movie that I've got to watch we
gotta shut all the lights off gosh
where's the remote
oh another thing that I'm excited to
connect to this TV is the new Xbox that
will be coming out later this year
taking full advantage of 4k and HDR
gaming is gonna be really awesome to
test out on here
as I mentioned gaming you might be
confused as to why there are two
monitors sitting up when I have this
massive huge TV that it could also be
gaming on so we had these stations set
up where we had three of us playing
destiny at the same time two people
could be playing on these monitor
stations here and the third up here on
the TV it definitely got a little bit
crazy and a little bit confusing because
we're all yelling and screaming and
sitting on this couch very very close
this is Maddie's little bed right here
so these two stations we have Astro
headsets hooked up to them and those are
just connected directly to the
controller these gaming stations
definitely aren't a permanent solution
but for the time being while I'm super
into destiny this is what we've got set
up here and this light right here is
definitely not something that I usually
have but I felt like it was kind of dark
over here in the corner so I needed to
put a little bit of light on myself
I love these light panels they're small
compacts and they're really easy to use
there's one also behind my desk which is
kind of permanent back there I use that
a lot when I'm shooting sort of like the
iPhone room or videos when I'm sitting
at my desk this is actually Matt's
little small HD screen I need to return
it to him but I really like it because
it's easy when I'm kind of just on the
go of logging and I need to see what it
looks like because Sony cameras do not
have a flip-out screen come on this is a
new addition to the desk this is the new
movie wireless charger for the new
iPhones this is also a nice little apple
watch charger which doesn't really look
very good I got to get a new one extra
lens and these are some of my favorite
LEGO Minifigures beti Steve Jobs and
myself plus over here the original
iPhone that I just remind myself started
from the bottom now we're here so this
here is my editing station and this is
hooked up to my macbook pro this is the
USB Cu edition with the touch bar and
this
setup is not very organized but it works
for me I have it sitting here underneath
of my desk there's two hard drives
hiding behind it which I use for
archiving footage back and X up here to
this Mac monitor which I've been using
for a very long time and I'm so looking
forward to iMac Pro or potentially Apple
releasing a new monitor because I would
love to have something to connect to my
macbook pro I used these little Samsung
SSDs and these are so great because
they're very very fast especially when
I'm editing off 4k footage these are the
t 3s and this is one of the new T 5s
that I just got and I thought that I
wouldn't be able to tell a difference in
speed but actually I kind of can is that
good
there we go it turned some lights on so
over here this is what I used to do vo
this is the Razer siren mic and I
actually really really like this because
it allows you to also monitor your audio
and it usually sounds pretty good for
everything that I need it for this works
very well to make it sound like I'm
actually in some sort of a studio or
something when clearly I'm not
hey what do we got over here gotta move
this light over here so this will look
better from the office so over here this
is where I have my surface studio and
you guys probably are like just scene
why do you observe a studio so this
surprisingly replaced my gaming computer
I wasn't really doing much PC gaming and
the PC gaming that I did do this was
perfectly fine for it it completely
eliminated the tower don't get me wrong
I absolutely loved having an incredibly
overclocked powerful PC that's water
cold it was huge it's a tower its
massive I didn't need it it was super
clunky and it was basically overkill for
anything that I was doing number two I'm
not using it to its full potential so I
plan on actually putting that in another
place to have a completely separate
gaming PC set up for anybody who may
come over who wants to play PC games or
stream but for me right now in my
current state of me still editing my own
videos I don't have time to do anything
except shoot and edit and when I do play
games I'm playing for my own enjoyment
not to stream or post or edit any more
gaming content because I don't want to
add any more to my plate a lot of these
days maybe if I get somebody to edit
half
my videos I'm mostly even playing Diablo
3 I know
Diablo 3 yes I've been playing again it
was one of my most favorite games ever
overwatch actually runs really well on
here and of course minecraft also over
here connected to the PC I've got this
our MC babyface audio interface which is
connected to this sure microphone this
microphone is way better than the saira
that I have over there so depending upon
the project or what I'm doing it will
sometimes switch these microphones back
and forth or I'll record the audio over
here take it to the Mac and next to that
this is my Astro mix amp next to that is
my Super NES classic next to my Nintendo
switch that is also decked out in
classic NES decal style it looks so good
I cannot wait for Mario Odyssey and
below that attendance which we've got
the PlayStation 4 Pro and then below
that we've got the Xbox 1s which is
connected to a monitor at the couch
let's just completely ignore my lack of
cable management please which leads us
back to the LG wallpaper TV and what
this sound bar is on this is the dilemma
that I'm not sure what to do and I first
started doing an office reorganization I
thought hey maybe I'll just get rid of
these desks then I realized that I'm
very attached to these desks and I
absolutely love the look of them
so then figure out how to make this work
but the problem is this center console
is actually just a dresser from one of
my bedrooms and it does not fit the
sound bar at all so I'm looking for a
really great media station to put here
so I have opened suggestions what do you
guys think I should do should i mount
the sound bar should I not mount the
sound bar I'm also working on something
else
that I will hopefully have installed
soon which will be a very very fun video
that I cannot wait for you guys to see I
will also probably need room for that
too so that thing will need room and
that thing is about the size of a PC
tower which is also one of the reasons
that I was kind of trying to make room
over here getting rid of one of the
towers anyway I feel like making this
video is kind of crazy because this has
been my dream office since I was I don't
even know since I ever started first
getting into tech now I used to watch
Leo Laporte and he still is one of my
favorite people ever I used to watch Leo
back in the day
when I was very very young me and my
grandmother would watch it all the time
after school we'd watch the screensavers
and I would see all of their crazy
setups that they would have and all of
the amazing tech that they were
reviewing and I was like man one day
that's what I want to do and it's pretty
crazy thinking back to my childhood self
and to be sort of living out that dream
of what I wanted to do when I was little
it's crazy to think that the jobs that
we are doing now they never even existed
when I was a little child like the jobs
that you guys are going to create that
don't exist now is going to be so
fascinating anyway that could be a whole
nother tangent and a whole nother topic
but what I am most excited about is that
I'm able to share with you guys my
excitement for things things that I love
and you guys share those things back
with me I'll see you guys in my next
video and I'll see you guys in the
comments until then I'm gonna use this
Christmas chapstick and go out of this
video could be flink destiny right now
but no I'm not
[Music]